we're concerned that people are
dismissing omicron as mild
even if omicron does cause less severe
disease
the sheer number of cases will once
again overwhelm health systems
we need to do two things
to prevent
severe disease and death
through vaccination
which is why the booster program that
was just discussed is so important
secondly we really must do everything we
can
to reduce
spread
and to
lessen the size of the surge by reducing
our contacts and doing everything we can
to stop transmission of this virus
and that does mean
wearing face masks maintaining physical
distance
keeping windows open and ventilating
and at the same time practicing superb
hygiene
including cleaning surfaces and coughing
into our elbows
it is vital this is a very serious
situation indeed
the rise that you're seeing in the uk
today is just the beginning of an
extraordinary acceleration there are two
epidemics going on
delta and omicron
and it is an emergency situation for the
british health service it will get
extremely serious within the next two
weeks perhaps quicker i do hope that
everybody who was watching that press
conference realized just how serious the
situation is it's serious in the uk it's
serious in europe and it's serious for
the world
well thank you for that i mean we do
have though high levels of vaccination
here um the booster program
is uh progressing 45 percent of adults
uh
now have received those booster programs
and uh uh booster jabs but you know what
is not clear is the proportion of cases
that will end up in hospital uh david do
you know anything more about
about that or is it we have to wait
until we get further evidence
thank you mark we are going to have to
wait it's not helpful
for people in my position to try to make
precise predictions
but i've been watching this pandemic and
working on it
since
january 2020
and i have never been more concerned
than i am tonight
not just about the uk but about the
world
even if omicron
is several times less unpleasant than
delta
i want to stress
the absolute number of people who are
going to get infected
some of whom will be people who've had
double vaccination
this absolute number
is going to lead to an already massively
stressed health system and health
workforce
being further overloaded and so it
really is important that every single
human being does everything they can
to protect health services by minimizing
social contact
and by doing everything possible to
prevent transmission of this virus so
that that suggests then that you're
supporting or calling for you know
social gathering is to be very limited
it's coming up to christmas um i mean
what are you saying here that we're in
the same situation that we were last
christmas because of course we do have
the the vaccines now but you're saying
that
limiting social contact is
as important as last year
i just cannot tell you mark
how serious the situation is going to be
i have no way
of predicting just how many people are
going to get omicron in the next three
weeks
nor can i predict
whether or not they will become severely
ill
we don't have the information nobody has
it
and so any prediction is just really me
expressing my hopes to you
but what i can tell you
is that we have enough information in
the world health organization to
indicate very clearly that this spreads
super fast with a doubling time of
numbers of cases
every two to three days
do you know what that means that means
that it will be eight times more serious
in one week forty times more serious in
two weeks three hundred or four hundred
times more serious in three weeks over a
thousand times more serious in four
weeks what i'm trying to stress is that
this will accelerate
super fast
if we are lucky
then we won't have high death rates but
we will still get
very heavy load on health services
and therefore on hospitals and a lot of
our friends and relatives are going to
get ill
it makes sense to do everything we can
to minimize contact to what is
absolutely essential now emotional
connections are essential and i don't
want anybody to think i'm trying to stop
that but i am saying only do what is
vital
so so you're basically saying
that uh
social activities over christmas have to
be limited
and we're in a very similar situation to
to last year i mean there are mps here
who stood up in the house of commons
yesterday and said that the government
here was scare-mongering and scientists
here were scared of course
yes i i want to talk directly to the
people who accuse us of
scaremongering i've spent 45 years doing
this kind of work
and my whole approach
is to do everything possible to enable
life to go on to enable fund go on to
enable love to go on
i want people to live their lives to the
full
i would only be making remarks about how
serious this is
if i had a very good reason to do so i
am concerned this is serious i don't
like comparing it to last year for me
this is unprecedented i don't know how
serious it's going to be
but i really do appeal to everybody
please take what i say seriously i'm not
speaking with any political message i'm
not speaking with any ideological
message i'm just speaking as a public
health doctor who is looking at the
signs listening to the experts and i
think we have a pretty serious problem
just uh coming up in in the coming weeks
and it's not just in the uk it's in many
other countries